[Music]
this is it yeah there's good you're in
the hot breath verse now man alright my
Mar breath is not hot enough to melt
this middle so that's a good thing
now you good actually I don't think my
breath is hot cuz I'm from Minnesota
it's more of a breezy room-temperature
Cola yeah definitely like a fish out
here I'm definitely like a fish and here
in the waters of Lake Minnetonka ah
Prince I am purified so multiple times
don't pick soap hurry Shannon and I wore
my Vikings head so yeah I know so yeah I
know y'all stole our um our design for
our stadium I seen y'all stadium I was
like oh yeah some biters bro that was
from yes though like whole stadium is
yours like 1.6 billion they just they
just built ours two years ago oh really
this US Bank Stadium just the roof
though right wow I was like I am
actually so what happened is they had to
get what is it a falconers yeah cuz
people were flying drones into the they
would open it up and people fly drones
in and just be watching the game on
their drones Wow I had to get falconers
with Val keys yeah to go get them
get the drone and then bring it back
down that's just so funny crazy right
yeah I'll have to go through that trust
me soon as they sometimes they stood
sometimes they start opening up that
that thing
they'll start flying drones and what's
the future oh yeah that yeah appreciate
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're all
ready we got all the shops and
everything all right Bruce Leroy yeah
we're the other camera cuz I've seen it
but I ain't see it what you paranoid no
I mean paranoid I got it you got a
you've on the run right now got a hidden
camera here somewhere all right there I
saw from the movie magic from the loom X
Joey huh yeah give me a thin camera like
that because mine is heavy I got the
yeah I got the 5d Mark four so that
thing is about 12 pounds it's not as
easy to travel with and cuz that shoots
4k also yeah so like it's kind of
everything you need but with you have a
multimedia company like you do you know
I mean I only really need it for this
and maybe taking photos but you may need
for more substantial projects yeah maybe
not that's my baby man is actually more
to my children i I put more resources
into that care you have children have
two kids my oh my god I think they mind
- so I'm yo how old are you first 33 bro
Susan is 33 you have two kids you have
multi media company you have your own
comedy club yeah I'm 30
okay I have a dog a bike I don't have a
bike man oh you don't got a bike you
better get to have a set old golf clubs
do they still fit though are they like
kids we gotta bend down hill and I just
have them because I've never clubs in my
garage that I ain't I know my dad bought
them for me when I was like 15 so what
came first not the clubs or anything but
like in your in this whole kind of
you're building a seems like you're
starting to build your own platform
because we're to my podcasting off the
air as well so it's like what did you
start doing comedy first like what kind
of sparked this creative Empire you've
kind of started to develop it was the
visuals first okay actually I got into
media because I knew what I wanted to be
on stage or in front of a camera and I
was playing call of duty bro I had just
brought I'm a halo guy so I'm like Call
of Duty those those transfer that skill
transfer I got call of duty and some
little eight-year-old was kicking my ass
bro
whooping me talking mad [ __ ] too and I
was like man you know I [ __ ] this game
and I took the game and I took all of
the controls and I had to like a ps3 or
four which everyone was Xbox all the
games all the controllers I took it back
the Best Buy I was like yo take all of
this give me my money back and they're
like we can't give you your money back
sir but we can give you store credit
uh-huh and it gave me about a grand and
I was like what can I use in Best Buy
and I bought a camera and then learn how
to use the camera and so that's how my
multimedia company started
how old were you 23 because you went to
school for like the graphic designer
visual my degree is an occupational self
occupational safety and health
management with a minor and security so
I worked in that field all the way until
last year oh I thought I saw you went to
like Indiana State for like graphic I
thought it was like marketing no I was
one of those kids that changed their
degree field like 90 times I started off
with computer information systems then I
went to graphic design then I went to
Business Administration's
then I went to something else and then I
went into safety you know like you know
I don't want to be a sophomore for
another three years right what do I have
what classes do I got doesn't gonna get
me through this yeah so what I'm really
looking to get out of this interview
also is it's just funny I love this it's
been doing this podcast for so long it's
so funny that people you run into and
I'm like we're out at a comedy club me
trying to connect with finesse Mitchell
for an interview and we end up
connecting and I'm like yeah we should
definitely do this podcast appreciate
you and you're a comedian but what I
think so important also is you're so
much more than just the chameleon
and I think as comedians we can get
caught up in that one dimension of like
I'm a stand-up and this is what I do but
now more than ever and I know this just
personally and from interviewing so many
people now is like being one thing is
not enough it's heart is hard to
specialize yeah and but even if likes my
Cesar on stage like even if it's like a
Booker like somebody in the quote
industry they're in okay what else do
you have can you act do you have a
podcast like what are your other skills
so you you're almost like a Swiss Army
knife so yeah I definitely want people
to be able to learn from how I even been
able to develop so many different skills
you can become proficient at them okay
and also just your overall just creative
process you know my my thought process
basically around this whole thing oh
well maybe and maybe I had is something
that I had to develop over the time was
I want to be able to create my own
opportunities
hmm I don't want to have to be in the
quote unquote rat race if I don't have
to like I mean you sometimes you have to
be in a rat race just so that people
know who you are and you can you know
see the other people in there but at
some point something that you do has to
separate like you say separate you from
the pack right you know and so I started
doing all type of other stuff and then I
started to see that oh there's rat races
for each of these different fields so
what if I start to combine all those
together what happens and since I've
been doing that it's like oh look skip
the line here skip the line there oh
[ __ ] let me keep doing this so how do
you develop different skills there's new
[ __ ] bro I tell people all the time just
if there's something that you like to do
just do it even if you don't know that
know if you can do it just start you
know cuz once you start the process um
your brain starts to thinking about it
and you start to break down okay well
how can I do this different this work
and what you start that pattern what you
start on a journey you learn new things
about something that you've never done
before and you just you can they might
apply to other journeys that you're on
yeah that's that's a dope part about it
that's what I found in creativity is
like maybe graphic design will also
inform how I start to look at how I
write my
and adding new layers and thinking about
the hierarchy of my material just like
you would like the hierarchy of like a
poster or whatever do you find that
interaction to be true also yeah yeah I
do
especially in comedy well cuz comedy you
can get on stage and talk about whatever
you want to write and so I can talk
about being a yoga instructor and my
class I do Thai I mean I talk about my
yoga class I talk about you know having
Photoshop people that you know don't
necessarily want to pay for the
Photoshop I got I can talk about you
know being at work you know so the more
things the more topics that I have that
there are another rat race pack then
there's more people that can you know
that it resonates with haha and then I
can start to go to different events
where it's only Yogi's or only vegans or
only people in multimedia and I'm not
trying to always get on a comedy club
stage I can go to a conference or I can
go do you know a event that's specific
to vegans you know shooting for niches
oh hey that's what I was trying to
figure out which morning would that
little-ass you did a little thing in
front over to II and I was like yeah is
a niche or niche cuz my mom told me
niche but I know sometimes her words
don't be doing what she think they do
I've been heckled I've said niche on
stage and I had a lady yard
it's nice I've been saying nice but then
I wasn't sure if I was saying is it
right cuz I do not want to sound like I
got a niche that I'm doing people are
gonna be like a niche it's Isis or ISIL
whatever you wanna say whatever fits the
flavor nice and slow so you're you're
looking for niches will go with niches
niche this one good news I'm not even
looking for them I'm using the ones that
I have and I'm capitalizing on like
literally it's crazy that there are
opportunities out there as people doing
all type of [ __ ] that you're doing and
you might not necessarily know because
you don't really like push the issue or
push the envelope for that I mean not
you specifically but you could be a
freaking mechanic mm-hmm and there's a
mechanic's conference somewhere
but you're also a comedian you're like
hey y'all want some comedy I know I
talked about being my life as a mechanic
so how about a you know a 30-minute set
you know I'm sure you guys got a budget
2500 for you and I'll make like three
grand how do you since now they find me
but I started to purse to him I started
to go to those events and I started to
just Network like hey I had to do this
and then once I got my TV credit it was
a lot easier so once I got that TV cred
in Minneapolis it's a little bit
different because here in Atlanta those
opportunities come you know twice three
times a day in Minneapolis those
opportunities are very few and far
between so once they happen everybody
knows and once everybody knows they said
okay well how can we get something
different in and me being in Minneapolis
it's like seven black people up there so
they're like oh and your black box got
him in here we got one y'all so with
food I feel and it's like the opposite
yeah it's like oh you're white
because I've been looking for hot dish
and casseroles for a minute I couldn't
so you like get on you like actively get
on google or Eventbrite and seek out
like a yoga event or let me let's
whatever your passion is you know it's
nah no I came to say that I do that yet
I'm probably because we don't have been
bright and popping like that up there
it's popping here now I know about that
because I've been here but there is you
know Facebook these cool and you just
got a beat and just doing stuff like I'm
going to yoga classes and people are
like I know you from a comedy club and
I'm like yeah like well you know what I
don't even coming up you think that I'm
like you got a budget and they're like
way more than what the comedy club is
playing you know so how did you eat cuz
it's so crazy the comedy club it's
called bad he's yeah it hasn't been open
that long it has in February we opened
our Club location February of 2017 we
started
the brand and about obviously august's
are may of the the year before 16 and it
was really like like I said we were
three black comedians trying to get on
at clubs where it wasn't whole bunch of
black comedians they're so you know
they're like we don't want to scare our
audience away with your Urbanus even you
yogi the beard tie is threatening
threatening right not ODB you can't come
in here but no whoo tang clan in here so
it was hard for us to get on stage bro
and so instead of trying to fight fire
but so many of you like let's create our
own opportunities and in doing that we
found that there were a lot of people
that were looking for that same
opportunity okay so we opened the door
that allowed you know tens 20s 30s you
know other comedians to have a place to
practice because that's what comedy is
about if I can't get on stage and work
material out yeah I'm never gonna be
able to get to the point to where I can
deliver in front of a audience mm-hmm
and so we gave people that opportunity
and also gave ourselves the opportunity
because I mean before baddies I was on
stage maybe once a week twice a week but
baddies gave me the opportunity to be on
stage like six times in a week
and so now I'm working [ __ ] out that's
what it takes to yeah I live on stage
man yeah yeah and so now I have an
opportunity to like I mean even the so I
did the hardest hit the Kevin Hart TV
show which by a no big deal the club
opens up and then all the sudden Kevin
Hart's like hey let's film a TV show it
was just dope man we had a couple people
live here for us man and a couple people
saying hey you guys should go there just
because of our story and everybody knew
how we came came about but once once
that happened it opened a lot of doors
for all three of us and other comedians
in this Twin Cities so that was that was
definitely a big thing but I forgot what
I where I was going at the beginning of
that it was the baddies origin story
well yeah so what does the name mean
also
one of our owners is a pervert okay and
so that's a good branding yeah so the
the the goal was to be like the Hooters
of comedy oh my god have baddies
everywhere running around and that's
what we did like he he this little guy
his name is Brandon really shout out to
my boy Brandon he is the king of the
friendzone I swear to God like this dude
is amazing at you know that the talent
that he can bring in off of his friends
on this is crazy we had beautiful women
you know basically volunteering for
weeks and weeks at a time to help us run
this comedy club and people were like oh
we didn't know we'd be like you got as
Brenda cuz I don't know none of these
both of us had a female both me and
Pierre had female counterparts at the
time and so we had to be like
counterparts yeah you're wondering man I
ain't married I ain't married he got a
wife I had a girl okay yeah yeah so it's
different
we have FINA female counterpart of those
yes I like that you have a female
counterpart next time I highlight
something you got a girlfriend
I got a counterpart and her part a
paramour just spirit man so yeah that's
where the name came from it just was
beautiful women baddies all over at all
times okay you know I really thought you
being this the spiritual guy that it
went deeper than that but it's really
just bad bad he's my spiritual man show
is because of the other side I got to
have something to break that up I need
it it's definitely the yang is
definitely like I started practicing
yoga because I was going crazy I was
like spazzing on people I was like I
need someone you mean back go there tell
us about him it wasn't necessarily
rock-bottom I just was I don't know want
to say a had a temper
but I was ready for action
at all times like if it had to go down I
wanted to know where it was gonna go
down cuz I was probably gonna jump it
off
okay and that can lead to trouble and
you know I was like in my twenties it
wasn't College no more it wasn't you
know cool to just be getting in trouble
like that it's all I had to have
something that was kind of just bringing
me down and it was accident I didn't
know that it was gonna do this I started
doing yoga just on just on a humbug man
I follow a girl into a class uh-huh you
know you go to like one of them big-ass
gyms and you'll necessarily be following
her but you know which way she went
don't put me in there yeah you know it's
a whole bunch of things going around
that corner that's what I call thanks
it's a whole bunch of things going
around that corner what is around that
corner and I walked around the corner
and I start smelling eucalyptus and the
lights got low and I seen things ranging
from aged like 22 to like 87 and I was
like what is this I went into the class
and I was didn't I mean I figured that I
would be able to know what I was doing
cuz athlete but it was super difficult
and I was sweating because I didn't know
it was heated and I failed it had been a
long time as I actually that I had
failed I do like all-american right yeah
yeah yeah when I left the class I was
like yo that was nuts and the next day
my body felt amazing I was like yo I've
never felt this good after working out
ever
and I was like addicted after that and
then after that you know it just was
like I was seeking it out I was like
where's the yoga and it kind of the
spirituality of it just comes like I
didn't even have to really dive really
deep into it like imagine this if I'm
trying to balance myself upside down or
even on two feet in a on a tightrope I'm
focused so hard on controlling my body
there's nothing else that can be on my
mind and so that was my realization that
I was in like the right now
and being in the right now moment is so
refreshing because you're not worried
about any moments previous or you're not
worried about what you got to do after
you leave here you are right here in the
moment figuring out yourself and that
was stupid powerful for me I mean once I
realized what was happening I was like
oh yeah I need this and I need to show
other people about this especially other
people from my neighborhood because we
spaz out if we need to spaz out and
sometimes you can just be like let me
just be right here for a second and
bring myself back to you know then must
help on and stand up to wait with
breathing and being more relaxed onstage
specially that moment right before you
go onstage cuz that's the worst moment
is right before you go out there you get
that empty just like when you're running
track if you ever anybody that ever ran
track knows if you're running like the
four-by-four right before the race you
get that empty feeling in your stomach
it's like oh I don't want to do this
because I know what I'm gonna feel like
afterwards but in comedy it's different
but it's the same feeling prior to that
nervousness that anxiousness like I just
want to hurry up and get this over with
it it helps with that because now I just
breathe
you know I saved my little mantra and
then I go do my thing what's your mantra
you are enough you are enough yeah and
you just like when you say your mantra
you repeat it multiple times like how
what is your pre-show kind of ritual
that um so I'm not yes basically before
I go onstage I'll do deep breaths I'll
go to myself and I do deep breaths and
each breath out
inhale with you are and then I exhale
with enough and I'm in hell you are
exhale three times and then I'm good
okay
so it's like as you're inhaling you say
you are in your heads
yep and out through your mouth or out
through your nose yeah it's you watch so
it's really so hum okay so Hobbs also
try it so you don't say that loud it's
all in your head right kind of yeah but
into your nose out through your mouth
well you can say soul with inhale so but
so is almost an exhale
it's just it's really just a movement of
air and how wolf you are is a movement
of airs I think it's something if you
hear that sound you hear it could be
something to suck in some air in really
fast or something that's blowing some
hair out so it's opening on air
literally it's just literally me telling
myself and affirming the fact that
whatever I do is gonna be okay cuz it's
gonna happen there's gonna be another
moment okay let's let's do this for the
listeners everybody listening hopefully
they'll be doing this with us now I'm
ready so guide us through it okay so the
first thing you want to do is just relax
yourself
don't be tense anywhere relax your
muscles if you're sitting down if you're
sitting down it's best to have your feet
on the ground okay because that's gonna
help you straighten your back the
alignment of your spine now I'm in a
taller seat so I have an angle at my
legs a little bit but having your feet
on the ground inhale as big as possible
you can do that three times
there you go every one more last time
inhale as much as possible fill your
lungs up fill them up there you go
and then exhale completely empty your
lungs almost engage your core right
there there you go yeah you hear that
last part of your friend that's it's the
prana that's it namaste namaste bro
you're welcome hot breath over everybody
in the studio is just like it definitely
got warm in definitely got warm you see
- yeah if you need any water we got the
font us water going on in temperature
dobro so it's really cool I appreciate
that it's rude let me say so is this
spring water spring water okay y'all
okay here is it bottled at the source I
have no idea hey Cheers my bad man oh
good Cheers
I rock with it now rock with it
I know you do the 50 days of water
challenge research bro we out here man I
like that yes I do a lot of water bro
water is my stuff yeah that's what
Tierra Burrell who was on here last week
was talking about water and people think
of as a liquid but it's actually like an
element because Tierra is like vegan
over 10 years she's like a guru of the
lifestyle she might know a little bit
more about the whole elements of course
is the element but to me water is the
beginning of a change for me that's why
I do 50 days waters like that is the
first step like the easiest step the
freest step right can do to promote
change and I just did it for discipline
I was like working I was doing all these
different businesses and I got to the
point to where I was drinking a Red Bull
with my dinner every night yeah sure big
battery can like the big one hey like
the 3/4 dollar one nice to get one of
them and I should just have it on the
table with me and drink it and that
probably affects your temperament too
like that some weak top-up Tierra's like
it's not like you are what you eat it's
like you eat what you are yeah it's how
she framed it and just like it affects
your overall cognitive ability and what
you're actually putting in your body
it's crazy there's so many little
aspects to how you how you function and
how you move that you don't even think
about you know and water at what you put
in your body is definitely one of them
but your environment yeah so many the
things what you're going through you
your family your job all of these things
contribute to who you are as a person
and how you deal with people the first
like I said he waters the easiest thing
like I drink a whole bunch of other
stuff but if I stop and I actually pay
attention to what I'm doing and I insert
discipline by forcing myself to not
drink anything else but water and then
watch my body or much higher response
you'd be like oh wow so the challenge is
in a specific amount of water it's just
to only drink water and in 50 days my
experience with the whole amount of
water thing is there is no universally
agreed upon amount of water that you
should drink just because everybody does
something different you know somebody
might be hitting doors all day somebody
might be running laps or running miles
depends on what you're doing so drink
whatever you are comfortable with
drinking but listen to your body and
watch your body like you know you watch
your color your pee if you if the pin
and it's brown bread you should probably
drink a lot more water
yeah you know I'm saying there's other
things that go into that but just listen
to your body and your body will tell you
what you need third when you're thirsty
you should have been drinking water yeah
I think it's important especially for
comedians when we'll be doing shows out
at bars and all that I think a big part
is the environment peace of surrounding
yourself with people you want to be like
so if you already open mics and there's
a comedian you gravitate towards there's
a comedian that's doing a lot of things
like you are like I gravitate to you
because you're like on Photoshop and
this comedy club like you do all these
different things and I'm like that's
what I want to be more like that mister
I gravitated or gravitated towards each
other because I see I was like oh okay
yeah I mean it's really a culture
especially in comedy like I'm in clubs
right all the time
you know I'm getting approached by women
all the time I'm getting a pro here I'm
getting approached by me
so it's different because you can you
can just let go and just fall into that
and you know it is gonna definitely take
a toll on you it might be a good toll it
might be a bad soul but when you when
you have more control like for me and I
specifically did 50 days of water when I
came to Atlanta so that I wouldn't drink
smart because there's no telling what I
would run into there's no telling what
type of environment that I was gonna be
in I was not sure so I said let me make
sure at least my head is clear so that I
can make decisions and move I need to
move when I'm down there so it's really
been good for me because I've been able
to accomplish a whole bunch of something
now here so being like not drunk yeah I
mean I'm telling you if I have would
have had alcohol involved in this trip I
probably would not have been as
productive as I and it saves money -
yeah well I'm drink for free bread I'm a
finesse King oh you're bad oh yeah but
this I don't remember the last time I
pay for a beverage I mean it's just you
know building relationships with people
and then you know who the drunks are you
know who is buying drinks next thing you
know you we taking shots around the
table gotcha that's how I go man
so and getting back to the environment a
little bit you taping with Kevin Hart
and being in his environment and his
when you get into the orbit of people at
that level yeah yeah yeah you've got to
be able to take some lessons from it so
that's the whole thing that I was doing
there was a little maybe a little bit
different from other people like Kim
Hart was what he made like 100 million
last year in comedy like icon status oh
yeah of course
super icon and everybody is like a
little bit starstruck when they run into
him and when they meet him for me it
wasn't necessarily like that like my
goal was to be in his energy field let
me let me observe what you got going on
you move so that maybe I can pull from
that blueprint that you have and create
it for myself super dope what people
don't realize is I was on harder City
Season 2 episode 7 I believe Twin Cities
episode and this was the last episode
where they were actually coming the last
season season 2 was where he was
actually going to the place and going
into the club's so that was the last
time that that stuff was happening and
so it was a super dope because he
definitely helped our brand our comedy
burned with baddies he definitely helped
me as a you know my own brand but it
gave me the opportunity to see behind
the scenes how he moves and how he works
I didn't get to just sit and chill with
Kevin for the weekend and then like that
it was literally like alright Kevin's
gonna be here in five minutes everybody
ready places camera alright Kevin's here
get him on stage do your thing alright
Kevin's out of here peace that's what
I'm talking about the operational side
was like I was like yo that's how it
works yeah and I didn't know that before
I was in the dark and so looking in and
so now that I know that I have a much
better understanding of how things work
so when I run into situations like that
and I'm meeting people that are on that
level it's not a personal thing for me
I'm like okay cool let me observe let me
be a sponge real quick take all my notes
saying get you know that information as
well at the opportunity but I'm here to
get that information because some way I
might be able to use that and or help
somebody else if they're trying to
figure out how to do that right or
they're going through that situation
this is how it's gonna go type situation
how do they even baddies was so new and
you said you had people vouching for you
like how man I don't know how it
happened but I know that we definitely
had people that were saying hey you
choose baddies um I'm not sure exactly
who it was I know we had the city of
many other twin cities vouching for us I
know a comedian named shaggy he's one of
my old G's and comedy I know he might
have vouched for somewhere I know the
city the
like the city was like hey these guys
are doing something okay and then we
also we were working for it too like me
and my brother Pierre the other owner of
baddies we went to go see Kevin at his
book signing he did a book signing in
the Mall of America for Ironman yeah
yeah we know that he's about to do that
let's go see if we can put a bug in his
ear and a crazy part about it is when we
got there it was the same situation it
was like here take your picture with
Kevin get off stage and so we developed
a plan like okay you write after me you
say the first half of the sentence
finish the end of the sentence yes and
so he got up there he was like hey I'm
Pierre I'm a baddies comedy club and he
was like baddies oh yeah I know about
that we're gonna be there and like I was
like he was like yo he said he already
know and I did I froze up take my
picture and I got up out of there and
then like within a week we heard I got a
phone call that said they were gonna
come and Scout our location and then
from there it was up to us to kind of
just you know shark show who we were
tell our story and see if they picked us
and it happened like that so we
definitely put in work it wasn't just
you know given to us we we were working
for it and we were making moves to make
sure that you know what we wanted was
gonna come to us but it definitely was a
blessing that came you know unexpectedly
you know you expect something but you be
you know you submit and forget matter of
fact I posted that on my Facebook today
you submit what you need to submit to
get what you need and then you let it go
let's let the universe have it and don't
worry about it don't think about it
because if you're supposed to get it
it's for you there's nobody else to have
your opportunities specifically for you
yeah and that opportunity was for us I
think that's a big thing for comics is
so many are so lazy yeah or it's it's I
don't know there's almost like an
entitlement in terms of but I'm an
artist that I'm on stage and I have this
message and to be able to almost think
in terms of like you said we didn't just
stumble upon the opportunity for Kevin
Hart to tape at our club we were
for that yeah we was working so I think
it's important for people to understand
that it's cool to have high ambitions
but then take away the entitlement of
it'll happen because I'm me
yes we're like no set the bar and then
jump for it yeah very much so very much
so it's like it's like anything you do
man you have to have a idea of what you
want and excuse me start to put forward
action towards getting there hmm
and it could be little small steps I
actually recommend that people take
small steps and when you can take a big
step take that big step and that a big
step number but a whole bunch of small
steps all at once you know I'm saying so
you got to take steps towards it now
there's definitely anomalies I don't
know if that's the right word but
anomalies in that in those different
situations to where hey look at the draw
we got we picked you but those are very
few and far between if you're taking
steps towards what you want the universe
is gonna send it to you in some [ __ ] way
shape or form that's how I feel when
you're developing all these different
disciplines like whether I mean whether
it be the graphic design like what all
maybe run down run down your resume
really quick in terms of like all the
different skill sets maybe your your
kind all the different plates you're
spinning maybe let's start there so I'm
a father that's the first thing and my
father of two
I had a one-year-old and a five-year-old
congratulations I'm so sorry but you
know they're they're so motivating bro
like so I've heard yeah I
my goal is to make sure that they
understand that you don't have to fit
into the box you don't have to do what
everybody else did like bro I I went I
got my college paid for I was on a full
ride scholarship athletic I graduated I
worked for fortune 500 for my entire
career then I went and worked for the
state of Minnesota everybody wants to
have a government job and then actually
when I got vested in the state I took
that they matched my 401 K I was like
whew that's it for me I'm gonna take
that money I'm gonna buy equipment so
that I have
thing that I need for my business and
then now I'm gone so I did what I was
supposed to do and after that I said oh
now I want to do what I want to do but
now that I'm doing what I want to do I
realized that I could have been doing
what I wanted to do a long time ago I
just had a fear of leaving that box and
everybody else you know they they also
they fed into my fears you know like
even when I quit my job and I put my
two-week notice in that was huge for me
because I always got fired
I never put two weeks ago I always got
fired and so for me to put two weeks in
and tell you tell them that I was
leaving was like so liberating like I'm
I'm about to do what I want to do and
crazy part about it is at my job even
the people were like oh so what do you
mean you're what do you mean you're like
30 how are you gonna do it
they can't even wrap their minds around
how to live outside of having a job
working for somebody else
my goal is to not be working for nobody
else my goal is to create something that
I can pass on to my kids that will be
theirs and you know you were ready to
leave your job that's a big leap for a
lot of people I knew that I was ready
because I would go to work and I would
be more I would not want to be there but
were you financially prepared no oh so
you just took the jump
we're on blind faith very much so did
okay I knew that I had four or five
things that I could do that wouldn't
make money okay so you had it wasn't
wasn't blind then you were like probably
a plan and turn I had a thousand bucks
in my bank account okay that's real you
know not a whole bunch of much real yeah
thousand in total and all of them
together that means this one got sixteen
this one got seven thirty 38:22 you know
altogether it was about a thousand
dollars and I was like yo with this
thousand dollars I can do a whole mean
Facebook Ads don't cost nothing you know
I know that I know my way around media I
know my way around my city I know I made
my way around doing things at a high
level to where I can monetize my
I have intellectual property and I
started to listening to listen to audio
books and stuff that entrepreneurs were
doing like my favorite one was the
4-hour workweek that Tim Ferriss never
rang right to me I was like 4-hour
workweek that sounds like what I want to
do so for four hours you work your
business and then the rest of the time
you have either to build another
business or to kick it with your family
or whatever you want to do in those
other hours so feeding my mind with
those type of things started to send me
in a different on a different thought
pattern of how to attack this and it's
definitely you know a journey is
definitely trial and error I definitely
didn't immediately go into into being
rich or anything like that I know that I
started that I started that path and
then things started to come so before
heart of the city even happened I did
this so before I was on TV
we had the club and the club was doing
okay but we wouldn't make an we wouldn't
make any money really we were just
making enough for it to keep sustaining
exactly yeah so we weren't making any
money off of that I was teaching yoga at
the time so I was making money teaching
yoga my multimedia company was doing
well so I was making money doing that
and that was pretty much it I had a
couple I had merged so 50 days of water
and 50 days vegan merge was selling for
that okay cool I could pay my bills I
could travel a little bit if I need to
travel but by far was not comfortable
but I stepped out on faith I took the
leap and my parachute opened up while I
was falling down hmm you know so it's
still not all the way open and slowing
me down from hitting the ground as hard
had a parachute I didn't know that
though I did not know that I had a
parachute on the whole time well I was
it probably was like when I when I put
took when I bought my camera that was me
buying the bag
and then you know all the little things
I was doing okay then I had the
parachute knit but I didn't know there
was a parachute on my back I thought it
was a weight that was holding me down
I'm thinking that this is a this is a
row Boulder on my back and I'm in this
plane if I jump I'm gonna flatten myself
at the bottom but it's a parachute back
there and I'm scared to jump but when I
jumped I started realizing oh you got
this he says yes you got this just use
it and once you learn how to use it and
what you start using it you start to
learn how to use it and you get better
and better and better at it and then
eventually that parachute opens up yeah
I think that self-awareness is the
parachute yeah and taking inventory
before like when I jumped into like full
time I did I made a list of like the
pros and cons yeah so like best-case
scenario and worst case scenario of
what's gonna happen yeah and taking this
leap yeah so it's not like you because I
all communes okay I want to be full-time
or whatever well it's not like well I'll
just be full-time and just to do an open
mic yeah you know but it's like go
full-time great but have some sort of
game plan take inventory on what your
skills are and how you can start to
monetize those to help supplement the
income you're gonna be losing very much
so okay and I think if you go into with
that mindset I think you'll be okay not
forever I mean somebody's gonna now go
full-time ago I heard operators go
full-time get it yeah work you have to
go get it because once you're a
full-time it's up to you you're gonna
know we're gonna see all your friends
doing all the stuff on the weekends
because they just got paid and you got
you got 15 invoices out and you waiting
for people to you know pay all that type
of stuff you know happens like literally
I have had times where I'm looking like
okay what am I gonna eat because I got
this food I gotta feed this to the kids
I don't gotten any you know I'm saying
but you know a week later invoice
randomly gets paid I'm like all thank
you Jesus you know that type stuff
happened so it's definitely a journey is
definitely a grind you definitely have
to accept the fact that you are in
complete control
it's up to you period nobody else gonna
give you nothing you know you if you
have family that can help
if you don't it's on you but period you
gotta go get it how do you attack your
days are you organized or you have time
management or like how how will you
attack on that here okay
I had a friend named Kimberly that I met
here she's also vegan and she's given me
a few tools since I've been here to help
my organ organization game I'm leaving
here with a whole new mindset and that's
the reason why I came here I brought
myself to a different environment to
pick up skills from people that are in a
busier you know environment like that
and I think it's important real quick
environment is also like like you said
you start listening to audiobooks and
different podcasts like that's part of
your environment as what's going on and
so you know I'm I don't know if it's
ADHD or ATD but one of my brain works as
like this like I cannot sit and do
something for a long time I'll get
burned out I'd be like no I can't even
look at this anymore I could be in the
middle of a project like I can't even
look at this little more I need to go do
something else and then I'll switch over
to whatever the other field that is I
mean and then I go hard on that for a
little while and then it might be like
I'm going hard for a couple hours or it
might be I get rien spired to go all the
way in on that it just kind of depends
on what's what's going on my environment
as well of timing is huge like right now
what's going what's gonna be good for me
right now to attack yeah and right now I
like being here I'm like okay it's time
for media attack this it's time for me
to attack this and it's time for me to
attack that because they're they're
watching me right now and there's a
capital it's a moment for me to
capitalize and put myself at the next
level mm-hmm so it's organized chaos for
me but now I have a couple tools that I
am going to insert in to help make it a
lot more organized on a you know from
the outside in what are those tools so
one of them apps
she gave me an app called Trello and I
think I had heard of it before okay but
I didn't have any organizational tools
like that Trello
lack is another one where you know I can
communicate with other people in another
it's almost like text messaging but you
can do it with your projects slack of us
another one she gave she gave me some
tools that helped me to look at my
social media analytics and I didn't
really care about none of that stuff but
now I know who's looking at me I did not
know that who my audience was and she
gave me to like okay this is who's
watching you and this is the second a
group is watching you and I was like
what off and I have my shirt off all the
time now I know that there's women
between the ages of 25 and 34 I'm gonna
be out here you go understanding now and
so now I can be more specific with how I
how I move mom so she gave me she gave
me so many gems and I'm super
appreciative she gave me so many gems
that I'm gonna take home and I'm gonna
use for myself but I'm also gonna tell
my homeboys like look this is what you
need this is what you need I'm also
gonna bring it to shorties like kids
like look there's this this this cuz
that's my goal is not only for my kids
but for the kids that are in my
neighborhood who don't know like they
don't I don't know how they don't have
idea that these resources are out there
it's not their environment yeah you know
I'm saying that they don't know that and
so if I can go back and be like yo this
is what you want to do this this is what
you do this is the first steps you do
look at this website go to creative
live.com and take the free courses that
they're gonna give you all day long go
do give give them resources so that they
can start to feed that monster and their
monsters just gonna grow and eventually
it could be something huge and you know
do you have any other insights for to
help comics start to feed that monster
is there anything that you found to be
helpful beyond organization or just for
comedy it cuz I really want to inspire
comedians to think beyond Timmy stand-up
is awesome that's my baby that's the
core but for them to start diversifying
their skills you know what I mean I
think that for comedy for me it's more
than me trying to
like I said it's a rat race everybody
wants to go to the comedy theater or the
theater and try to hustle their way on
stage which is dope you definitely want
to be able to get on stage and be able
to practice your stuff so definitely
practice your stuff but also go to these
places without expectation okay so don't
go expecting to get on stage don't go
expecting to meet nobody just go to be
around the environment talk to people
take time to talk to the people and see
what people are doing outside of comedy
because then you start to have a better
perspective of how other people are
advancing because if I didn't talk to
you I would never known that you had a
podcast like this right I would never I
would never seem to set up I'm dead I
walked in I was like oh no no take it no
oh no no no I'm saying it's all things
that you can utilize in your own realm
you know you might not be able to
utilize everything but I tell people all
the time and I tell this to my kids like
if you look outside all you see is cars
everywhere every car is has means that
there is one to eight people inside of
that building every person knows
something that you don't know every one
of them you know something that you
don't know it's up to you to pull that
out and it's something that you don't
know could be their own personal theory
and that theory could be the solution to
one of your problems yes so it's your
job to network and to talk to people and
to figure out how you can get that
information a lot of them I like that
going in without expectations even how
we cross paths yeah I was going to the
comedy club to interview finesse
Mitchell yeah and it was gonna we were
gonna squeeze it in in between shows and
it just got at the next show cuz I mean
yet this is hometown this is almost like
a homecoming tour for him so if the
timing didn't work out but we got to
meet each other and what was even cooler
is we instead of interviewing finesse
Mitchell I end up getting we end up
chillin in the green room with like him
and like maybe like three other people
for like two hours politic and I'm just
learn yeah like absorbing game from
everyone in the room very Muslim way
more useful than sitting with him for 30
minutes one-on-one because now we have
the relationship so when we do interview
do the interview he's gonna be
comfortable can be like friends yeah
instead of like well here's this kid who
just keeps hustling trying to worse it's
gonna be or whether you know you know
how it goes like can I interview like
wait who are you yeah now you built a
bridge with him built a relationship
with him and so now he's like oh Java
sup bro you know and it's gonna be a lot
smoother next time it goes oh yeah man
no extabit it's no expectations for me I
definitely have things that I'm really
like if you stay ready you ain't gotta
get ready and definitely on that wave
but I don't have any expectations I'm
I'm cool about it I'm gonna I'm going to
lobby for myself definitely but I'm not
gonna stress because I know that at the
end of the day I create my opportunities
yes nobody else that creates the
opportunity for me if I want it I'm
gonna go get it period one of my
favorite quotes from doing this podcast
interview Chad who Bray who's the
producer of 85 South okay I love a bus
oh dude yeah yeah we interviewed him in
here and he I asked him like what was
the strategy behind building this like
platform he's like consistency it was
the only strategy just keep doing what
you're doing consistently and it'll
happen
yeah it's consistent learn you just
troubleshooting bro like you running
some black ding like man yesterday we
were filming my podcast and no we were
on film and we were actually going
through we were going through the
footage and I'm looking at the footage
I'm like yo what is this music that I
hear and I'm hearing music on the back
end all of the clips I'm like what is
this kind of find out my mic is picking
up AM radio frequencies
like what never heard of that before in
my life right and so now I'm googling
and figuring out and my homegirl she
found it but I'm like yo now I have to
now I know that there's things there
steps that I have to do to get rid of
that and that's gonna in the future
that's gonna cut the process down for me
now I gotta go in I gotta take out the
noise but I also got to equalize the
sign so I got is more steps that I gotta
do now but now that I've gone through
that I know for the next time that I'm
not gonna have to do that and that's
every journey this them small steps you
learn something every step you take you
to learn something you learn that was
the right step oh that was the wrong
step maybe I need to step this way a
little bit so it's definitely
consistency definitely keep going keep
doing it it's gonna come small steps
make the big different hue JH huge
difference so I'm hoping this hoping
this episode today really helped people
to start building a self-awareness and
also take inventory on what your
personal skills are yeah and then how
you can turn them into a business you
know take inventory I'm not just like oh
just stand up which may be right in
front of you but look in your peripheral
it'll graphic designer over here you
know I've done some acting I've done
some improv like really I've done some
copywriting like really look at what all
of your skills are and then start to
incorporate them into your entire
business and creative process very much
so I don't even give you my little
rundown I stopped on Mikey's like
literally it's like you know it's a
process everything is a process all the
things they do I mean all the things
that I do started off small startup
there's little small things and they
were after the the first small step I
evaluated if I was interested in
continuing that okay or no a lot took a
lot of small steps I was like yeah not
the same for me what is a small step
what would you consider following that
girl into the yoga class okay that was a
small step I would have never gone into
that yoga class is Yoga has us as a
stigmata about it being for women but
you know now that I mean it for a long
time I realize it when it initially
started there were rarely any women that
did yoga because it was known as like
for the Warriors and they were
back from battle or something like that
they would do yoga to get their bodies
back to you know functioning normally oh
I did not know that I'm now it's like
the smooth jazz of yoga so it kind of
put a different aspect of what yoga was
to me and like if you look at the way I
teach my classes and the way I practice
is it's difficult you know you'd be
looking like whoa why is he doing that
and you'll see that there's a lot of
strength and focus and athletic ability
involved you know so it's super dope
just that small step though was what
introduced me to it and then I saw that
it was eliminate up limitless
opportunities and room for growth
so I may have an interest in let's say
graphic design and then it's like okay
where do I start
all right let me go on youtube and watch
a tutorial and if it clicks with you
that one small step all right take the
next step something more specific about
graphic design or if it doesn't then a
move on yeah definitely cool well dude
thanks for this was real I appreciate
you having a sauce you know I try to
drip too hard fancy clothes you don't
mess around drown 3012 times since I've
been here like oh my god I love your
artisans boy dude artisans you played
that at the comedy club the other night
and I was like I've never heard that
I've heard that 12 times yeah and that
was last night yes dude like I'm not
even I'm not no cat no cash no got all
type of words and I'm gonna go back home
it'll be like huh like by like at
Minneapolis the word buy like the room
is by the refrigerator in the kitchen
[Laughter]
dude before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
hey world what's up yeah no just keep
going man keep doing your thing keep
moving forward you're gonna get
frustrated
it you're going to get you're gonna lose
your motivation but everybody does
some people just keep going some people
just push through my name is Bruce Lee
Roy Williams you can find me at
legendary Bruce on all platforms baddies
comedy calm baddies comedy on all the
platforms I just dropped a new podcast
called do fries come with that convo
which is a vegan plant-based podcast
super dope where my homegirl might be
vegan Kimberly
human luminous anybody say to my grandma
like it's human luminous so my name is
bruce leroy right the glow human
luminous is you yourself are light you
decide whether you're gonna be dim or
you're gonna be radiant so human the
luminous hu ma n lu mi in owe us and
your is that your multimedia company is
my multimedia company so within that
yeah i mean we can even just close with
this is like what are all the different
because some some i may even want to
hire you after hearing this so are all
the different what is the word jobs you
offer skills are slow a videography
photography graphic design motion
graphics websites with us it don't stop
like i didn't specialize so I learned
about 75% of the Adobe Creative Cloud
suite and just you know started you know
researching all that so I do everything
and I've tried to do everything so that
I can at least give you guidance on how
to find what you need I can definitely
outsource but yeah we do everything also
the goal is to heal through
laughter media and movement Bruce Leroy
thanks for hot breath man I appreciate
you know we out here yeah all day all
right I buy peace
[Music]
you